[Musique]
la drogue c'est de la merde
la légalisation du cannabis
est-ce que c'est envisagé est ce que ça
tue le trafic quel est votre avis et
c'est une htc dream htc n'acheter
totalement continent généralisation des
pénalisations viennent acheter
intellectuelle bernanos c'est la merde
on va pas légaliser cette merde c'est
une roma marchès j'ai 37 ans et ça fait
bientôt trois ans que j'utilise le
cannabis pour soigner et je n'ai jamais
été aussi soulagé qu'aujourd'hui donc
pour moi c'est un combat important avec
un ami sont enfin autorisés à niveau
le combat de romain est celui d'une
poignée de députés depuis deux ans
légaliser le cannabis médical est ce qui
est surprenant c'est que ceux qui sont à
la tête de la mission d'information ne
sont pas de gauche ils sont du même bord
que gérald darmanin aujourd'hui de
mettre souhaitons vraiment insister
c'est le sens de ce rapport d'étape sur
l'importance un autre sens de lancer
dans notre pays l'expérimentation du
cannabis médical qu'elle avait sa
location terreur et si je le disais
c'est une volonté du législateur et le
liban sont plus généralement qu'il ya un
enjeu qui est à la mode en ce moment
mais qu'il s'inquiète bien la question
du cannabis médical qui est d'un enjeu
de souveraineté économique
envisagé tant sur le plan agricole que
sur le plan sanitaire la construction la
constitution d'une véritable filière
médicale en france du point de vue le
cannabis thérapeutique et surtout bien
comprendre que ce n'est pas parce qu'on
légalise sur la possibilité d'utiliser
cannabis à des fins thérapeutiques qu'on
va vers la légalisation totale ça n'a
rien à voir ces deux sujets totalement
distinct et on les avait un distingué au
cours de notre mission et relu distingue
dans un rapport et c'est important à
noter je pense pour éviter justement de
ne pas du tout évolué sur la législation
au cannabis ce qui est le cas
aujourd'hui où la france fait partie des
cinq pays européens à ne pas s'être
lancé dans
dans ce défi je pense que pour les
patients ce n'est plus supportable oui
le ministre de l'intérieur a déclaré
récemment dans deux médias que c'était
une lâcheté de penser à légaliser le
cannabis
et il a même dit que c'était de la merde
un produit donc de la merde c'est dire
qu'en fait vous voulez donner de la
merde aux malades c'est sa
lâcheté c'est précisément de faire une
faute des débats
si vous voulez mon avis sur le terme qui
était employé par j'ai encore ma main je
crois que ce qui est de la merde c'est
surtout le trafic de drogue là ça c'est
damien oui après nous à ce stade on peut
pas se prononcer sur aussi
catégoriquement sur un produit dont on
voit qu'il a le visage sur une
blanquillos l'origine c'est en france à
faire des bâtiments ont des tableaux de
bord aux voitures et manifestement
gerber maintenant le sait pas si elle
apprendre le chante la cannabis est une
drogue oui c'est la vérité au même titre
que l'opium est une drogue ne sais pas
pour ça que ça ne peut pas aussi un
médicament
[Musique]
pratiquement généralisée en amérique du
nord et du sud le cannabis médical et
notamment légale en israël en chine et
dans 21 pays européens
la france fait figure d'exception où un
million de malades seraient en attente
d'une légalisation du cannabis médical
[Musique]
jean-baptiste moreau député éleveur de
bovins dans la creuse est l'initiateur
de la mission d'information sur les
usages du cannabis que des cd malade
vous oui je connais des malades de ce
sont les en plaques notamment qui
aujourd'hui font pousser du cannabis
dans leur jardin ou dans leur
appartement pour pouvoir se soulager oui
et hansen en plus c'est le doublement
dangereux c'est que ils savent pas
vraiment ce qu'ils cultivent et derrière
il le fume c'est dommageable pour les
poumons et donc il vaut mieux les
gélules il vaut mieux des dégoûte il
vaut mieux des choses comme ça que que
le fumer mais aujourd'hui n'ont pas
d'autres solutions dont ils le font
qu'est ce qui bloque dans la cité
française aujourd'hui qui fait qu'on est
les derniers de la classe un peu c'est
toute la mythologie qui entoure le
cannabis et c'est vraiment ça c'est que
des vous parlez de chambre ou de
cannabis voilà c'est le fumeur de pétard
complètement défoncée qui est capable de
bosser voilà c'est ça qui vient avec
vous avez certaines molécules dans le
cannabis le pense au cbdca nabi dionne
qui a un certain nombre de vertus et qui
n'entraîne pas de dépendance
particulière par rapport à ceux qui en
consomment donc voilà il faut sortir du
débat binaire ce bien mal le cannabis
c'est à la fois un médicament aussi
comme les opiacés peuvent en mettre en
hockey ont des passionne le débat pour
comprendre mais attention ce n'est pas
si simple
tout le monde l'a constaté le cbd est en
vente libre en france alors le cbc du
cannabis mais dont on a enlevé la
molécule psychotrope celle qui fait
planer dans le joint et qui s'appelle le
thc on achète du cbd pour son bien-être
mais aussi pour se soigner il ya des
gens qui le veut juste comme pré
l'accent alternative aux pétards il ya
des gens qui veulent ils ont des
maladies dans leur corps au niveau des
eaux qui n'arrive pas à dormir que les
voix qui tremble ep tout la rupture de
cbd et d'huile faut vraiment pourvu
s'est passé pas content parce qu'il
utilise comme un médicament un
médicament qui n'est pas reconnue par
les autorités sanitaires françaises tu
ne peux être vendues en pharmacie et qui
donc n'est pas remboursé par la sécurité
sociale
[Musique]
autre contradiction et pas des moindres
tout le cbd en vente en france est
importé les producteurs français en sont
exclus seuls les tiges et les graines
sont autorisés pour faire du textile et
de l'huile alimentaire plein d'oméga 3
pourquoi un nouveau voisin ont le droit
de transformer la fleur et de d'envahir
le marché français avec de la fleur
transformer et de la fleur et que nous
agriculteurs français chanvrier français
qui sommes le premier pays producteur en
europe de chambre n'a pas le droit
d'utiliser la fleur
alors en résumant le chanvre est le
cannabis c'est la même plante elle
contient du thc et du cbd alors que les
vertus médicinales des deux molécules
sont reconnus ailleurs aucun traitement
n'est autorisé en france
résultat des dizaines de milliers de
malades qui ont recours au cannabis sont
considérés comme des délinquants
[Musique]
on
oh
laetitia mère de quatre enfants
administre du cannabis à son fils well
il a 10 ans et pèse 11 kg
il est atteint d'une maladie génétique
rare il souffre d'épilepsie et de
symptômes type parkinson
depuis quatre ans laetitia donne des
gouttes de cbd et de thc à son petit
garçon
il est où sa [__] vous au cherche midi
un million de petits garçons petit bidon
il est où
l'idée ou le
cb dire
ça c'est froid
olala sco qui nous
on affirme empreinte
oh là là ce prince
voilà est-ce que c'est là la nutrition
ce que wayne ne mange pas de
depuis ces trois mois il mange pas par
la
mange pas par la bouche quoi du coup il
a une gastrostomie un trou au niveau
du ventre et il a alimenté par cette
manière uniquement
voilà il a eu son traitement
de cannabis c'est ça et maintenant il
fait son petit goûter
les traitements et canalplay bon coup
pour son âge beaucoup pour son poids en
qu'il a eue
pour l'épilepsie tout ce qui est bien
sûr des pipelines
il a eu les antidouleurs la morphine
des opiacés
du coup d'argent qui maintenant interdit
toute une liste en fait il souffrait
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps et une fois qu'on a passé toute la
pharmacopée et les maisons si on ne peut
plus rien pour lui en fait et
c'est durant trois mois on va dire et
alors qui a trouvé l'idée du cannabis
alors comme tout parent ont fi b g chez
commun comme les autres en fait puisque
on dort pas on cherche sur internet et
sur internet on trouve
une maman aux états unis
maman au mexique qui curieusement se
sont orientés vers le cannabis médical
ou cannabis thérapeutique selon comment
on souhaite la polir et nous avons dit à
la paix à la neuro pédiatre
bombay puisque rien ne fonctionne on va
passer au cannabis et la nati vous êtes
complètement folle moi je n'y connais
rien au cannabis je ne peux pas vous
donner
je ne peux pas vous aider d'abord parce
que c'est illégal
je n'ai pas les compétences pour
j'ai bien si vous m'aidez pas je vais le
faire quand même fait
donc la neuro pédiatre a accepté de nous
et y est abaissée des traitements un
parent progressivement jusqu'à ce qu'il
ne reste plus rien
elle m'a dit par contre le cannabis
c'est vous qui gérez
une fois qu'on a donc pratiquement tous
les six on a introduit des premières
gouttes de cannabis
est là
ça a été en 48 heures son premier jour
de liberté
quoi
tu veux des outils
tu veux faire bricolo et ça lui demande
une concentration énorme
[Musique]
d'attraper un objet
qu'est ce que je vais faire
d'effort
bravo
c'est pas dire
je tienne tête à dix médecins je sois
mon enfant comme je veux j'ai fait la
démarche d'aller vers les médecins mon
fils était très suivis
des hospitalisations n'en compte plus il
a fallu séparer la fratrie
les grands étaient à la maison le petit
à l'hôpital
j'ai consulté un avocat qui m'a dit
attention
c'est vous et vous risquez d'être
considérés comme trafiquant parce que
vous le fait de venir chez vous je ne
suis pas le choix en fait moi je veux
bien être entendu par un juge vient
d'arrêter je veux bien être de la
justice
et je lui ai parlé avec n'importe quel
juge
mais qu'est ce qu'on peut me reprocher
en fait n'est pas
de d'avoir voulu soulager mon enfant
en fait on traite pas on apaise on
accompagne qu'il parte j'accepte
j'accepte je veux pas le le pousser à
vivre il ira ce que jusqu'où il ira mais
ce que je ne veux pas ceux qui souffrent
je refuse qu'on aime dans un pays commun
comme la phrase en europe avec tout ce
qu'il existe je refuse qu'on allait
souffrir mon enfant c'est inconcevable
pour moi qu'il garde sa dignité
tout au long de du chemin qu'il a à
faire est ce que c'est dans un an est ce
que c'est c'est dans une heure est ce
que c'est dans dix ans ça à personne
aujourd'hui capable de le dire
je vais le dire
[Musique]
je
un an
[Musique]
on estime à 300 mille le nombre de
malades qui comme laetitia ont été
obligés d'inventer leur médication avec
le cannabis
certains médecins ont décidé de braver
le tabou et d'écouter ses patients
devenus en fait des experts c'est le cas
d'un psychiatre de renom
spécialiste de la douleur à clermont
ferrand il a travaillé à mettre en place
une expérimentation du cannabis médical
voici nicolas authier vous deviez me
présenter des médicaments vous n'avez
pas ça vous moi je n'ai pas de
médicaments oui réduite et belgique
amant clandestins vous en avez des
patients non importé des médicaments
qu'ils ont fabriqué à partir du canada
oui j'en ai ils sont beaux ils sont là
aller les chercher là
d'accord alors sondé des médicaments que
que l'on a reçus nous par les patients
ouais de façon à les analyser vous avez
ici par exemple une aubade way à base de
cannabis avec des extrêmes au toucher
non oui vous pouvez la toucher oui c'est
une pommade avec un extrait de cannabis
qui vont pouvoir s'appliquer sur des
zones douloureuses par exemple et puis
ils vont produire aussi
quelque chose qui se rapproche encore
plus d'une forme pharmaceutique ce sont
des gélules mais là dedans il y est du
cannabis et avait glissé bd et du thc
c'est le bonus on ne sont pas les gros
c'est pas si vous voulez vous vous dites
ok moi je n'ai pas à dire ok ou pas ok
impatients qu'ils auraient du cannabis
c'est pas mon rôle mais vous dites jouez
vous pouvez le prendre des pays ça peut
vous faire du bien le patient le prof le
patient il va pas attendre que le
médecin donc vous vous servez à rien
voix lorsque le patient me dit je prends
du cannabis
je vais travailler avec lui sur le
pourquoi il prend du cannabis quels sont
les effets qu'ils recherchent et je fais
surtout faire en sorte que ça ait du
sens par but thérapeutique et réduire
les risques et les risques ça défrise
angoisse elle risque de fa de la
somnolence et risque de faire de la
paranoïa par exemple il ya eu des morts
par un vent bien eu des overdoses et pas
l'overdose et non cannabis non ça
n'existe pas l'overdose de cannabis
complications
cardiovasculaires et pour les plus
graves rare il n'y a pas d'odeur dose
vous vous avez été à la tête d'un comité
qui a dit il faut légaliser le cannabis
thérapeutique auprès de l'asn qui l
agence nationale du médicament oui on
s'est penché sur cette question là
sérieusement pour la première fois en
france est officiellement surtout
officiellement dans au sein de l' agence
du médicament et pendant plusieurs mois
on a travaillé à partir de la
littérature scientifique on a auditionné
et on a pu en tirer comme conclusion
qu'il était pertinent de donner accès
aux à certains patients à des produits
qui contiennent des extraits de cannabis
pour certaines indications cinq grandes
indications desquels donc la douleur
neuropathique d'une douleur chronique
mais aussi les épilepsies résistantes
aux médicaments il y en a plus de cent
mille patients en france conserver
et puis aussi les situations liées au
cancer ou à la chimiothérapie
anticancéreuse
et puis lé soin palliatif qui parfois
peuvent avoir un intérêt lorsque les
patients ne supporte pas par exemple les
opioïdes enfin d'éradication une forme
de douleur qui est la spasticité dans la
sclérose en plaques ou dans d'autres
maladies de la moelle épinière qui sont
parfois mal soulagé et puis dans un
second temps il a fallu réfléchir à
comment il fallait donner accès à ses
produits alors là tu fous des salles
existent toujours puisqu'on n'a pas
abouti à une légalisation en france on a
abouti à un projet d'expérimentation ce
n'est pas tout à fait la même chose donc
deux on va tester l'accès à ces
médicaments en france pendant deux ans
pendant deux ans donc 3000 malades vont
pouvoir expérimenter le cannabis médical
c'est un grand espoir pour tous ceux qui
utilisent des drogues légales abbas
d'opium sans trouver de rémission à leur
douleur
[Musique]
romain qu'on a vu au début de ce film a
la chance d'avoir été sélectionné dans
l'expérimentation
la ccvd que je mets y appelait ya pas de
tâche est donc
là j'en ai fini
g36 produit la cdu ça c'est du chier
tout du pilot français a plein de noms
mais ça vient de la rue on sait pas
forcément ce qu'il ya dedans c'est ça
qui fait un peu sa dangerosité aussi
romain est atteint de la myopathie de
becker une maladie génétique rare il est
également greffé du coeur
de très violentes douleurs parcours son
corps il a essayé toutes sortes de
traitements mais les opioïdes que le
médecin lui prescrivaient le rendait
amorphe comme drogué
seul le cannabis un mélange de cbd et de
thc le soulage et lui permet de rester
lucide jeu
non car soir je vais quand même assez
mal dormi je vous l'attendez du client
dans celui là
oui font des travaux mettent aux normes
pmr
ils mettent aux normes pmr pour que je
puisse savoir si je roule en eau
électrique pour sortir enfin de chez moi
parce que deux ans et quelques
que c'est des escaliers donc là déjà je
commence à ressentir les premiers effets
je dirais pas psychologue dirai ça paie
ne savais que
ça fait un peu un peu comme si on avait
bu une bière ça fait juste fsdp la
voilà donc déjà j'avais mal aux
articulations et maintenant j'avais mal
là et maintenant ça a disparu presque je
suis passé de gta 8 sur 10 à peu près à
vie qui ont dit oui j'ai pas dormi à
cause de ça et là bas c'est redescendu à
ce qu'en fait les douleurs que ça combat
vraiment chez moi c'est c'est comme des
coups de poignard
dans le muscle ou d'effacer des chocs
électriques ou comme si on posait des
glaçons très longtemps sur une partie
de la scène
[Musique]
j'arrive à faire de la parabole thaler
dja est mal quand je vais là j'ai
quasiment au plus mal et maintenant
c'est ce qui permet de ce qui me permet
de garder une certaine autonomie
[Musique]
pour moi c'est moins compliqué d'aller
en machine arrière
j'ai vu sur les étagères il ya des
vivres un petit peu sur le japon lui
bien sûr une grand-voile gènes d'intérêt
j'avais la culture oui j'adore les mots
mais bon j'ai quelqu'un pour jouer avec
moi ça serait cool jusque là j'ai mon
univers un petit jardin zen
j'ai un peu planté
donc voila sinon
j'adore le côté jules verne c'est vrai
beaucoup
ça m'a beaucoup inspiré
et ça c'est le genre de livre ou quand
je plonge dedans des fois la douleur
jeu tellement plus dans le livre que
la douleur passe jules verne me fait du
bien je sais pas mais j'aime bien ça
c'est mon père et moi au bar en face
les montres chemine c est bien sûr et
voilà quoi
romain ne fume pas plus d'un joint par
jour quelques bouffées suffisent pour
calmer ses douleurs alors l'idée de
pouvoir se soigner en toute légalité
avec un produit contrôlé et sans avoir à
faire à des dealers est une belle
perspective
et puis il sait que pour ses poumons
fragiles il doit absolument arrêter la
cigarette
contrairement au cannabis le tabac en
mortels
c'est ici à l'hôpital de
boulogne-billancourt que romain va être
suivie dans le cadre de
l'expérimentation
[Musique]
sens de la douleur man show c'est une
première alors toute l'équipe est sur le
pont moi je pense qu'on va faire chacun
chaque médecin ici on peut être une
demi-journée cannabis par semaine je
sais pas un truc comme ça non tous les
pharmaciens et médecins du service se
retourner à l'école avec une formation à
distance suivie d'une évaluation
l'opium on connaît mais le cannabis il
faut tout inventer
donc comme traitement de fond on aura la
voie orale avec différents ratios donc
cbd dominant équilibré donc équilibré en
thc cbd était haché dominant et dans les
deux ratio c/b des dominants va en
discuter y en a un je suis pas sûr qu'il
soit vraiment facile pas sinon c'est le
tout premier parce qu'il est c'est
quasiment ya pas de grillage c'est quoi
notamment pour les patients qui fument
qui ont déjà fumé avec une proposition
de thc assez importantes commencent à
douter mais pas des tht tu t'exposes a
beaucoup plus de défections n'ont naïf
l'ami des séries chez les patients non
life de thc peut-être qu'on pourrait
même commencer d'emblée par un ratio
équilibrée saine discussion ça c'est
possible non life as we équilibré mais
l'évasion naïf ah non faut commencer par
un ratio de semer des dominants mais ça
c'est écrit après la
professeure attal dirige le service de
la douleur
romain est un de ses patients c'est donc
elle qui va le suivre
alors professeur et al vous participer à
l'expérimentation
tout à fait nous allons participer à
l'expérimentation cannabis avec l'asm
pour une des indications qui et les
douleurs neuropathiques réfractaires
quand vous avez annoncé votre équipe ils
ont été favorables ils ont été très
favorables oui parce que on a tous des
patients extrêmement douloureux pour
lesquelles on est désespérés parce qu'on
a beaucoup beaucoup de mal à leur
trouver des solutions thérapeutiques
acceptable je suis tout à fait favorable
à cette expérimentation pour je dirais
aussi changer les les plaies de l'image
du produit pour les patients c'est
évident pour les autres médecins et pour
les politiques
ça va nous donner une meilleure idée
déjà de la faisabilité ensuite ça va
nous donner aussi une meilleure idée des
effets indésirables dans la vraie vie
mais ça va quand même ouvrir des portes
je pense et permettre ensuite de faire
de vraies recherches sur ces produits
dans l'hôpital il y a comme une espèce
de bunkers c'est la pharmacie alors on
n'y entre pas comme ça et les produits
sensibles sont consignés dans une
chambre forte les nouveaux médicaments à
base de cannabis font partie de ceux là
alors vous êtes
dépositaire de ce trésor ça fait un
trésor ces médicaments je ne sais pas si
on peut aller jusqu'à 13 heures non
enfin ils sont protégés ont tous pleins
sont protégés tout à fait lorsque je
peux savoir la provenance de ces
médicaments
mais vous avez différents laboratoires
alors eu six un laboratoire israélien
little green c'est un laboratoire
australien
et celui ci c'est un laboratoire
canadien d'accord voilà pourquoi jour 12
importer ces médicaments parce que
actuellement en france le cannabis
médical n'est pas autorisée à la
production à la culture à titre vraiment
médical thérapeutique
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un sous titre santé
publique et de sécurité publique à la
fois important
est aujourd'hui l'un des plus grands
producteurs européens et chants de
change n'a pas le droit de cultiver des
champs ou du cannabis avec d'été chez
puisque c'est interdit la france est
donc absente du boom mondial des
médicaments à base de cannabis alors
certains agriculteurs sont en colère ou
d'autres émotions n'en a pas moins
aujourd'hui d'exploiter l'afflux de deux
chances de là qu'on a droit d'exploiter
la plante entière n'est pas la fleur de
chambre et qu'on s'est lancé un des
combats et pourtant les acteurs sont
prêts on est en ligne avec quelqu'un que
vous connaissez le connais très bien
vous êtes agriculteur des fondateurs de
l'afer mieux de pétrole elle se trouve
dans la dans la creuse et vous vous êtes
prêt à cultiver ce cannabis en cas de
légalisation n'est ce pas alors
déjà avant de pouvoir cultiver du
cannabis récréatif on aimerait déjà
cultivé du chanvre bien-être avoir la
possibilité de
d'exploiter la flore de chanvre
industriel ce qui nous est interdit
actuellement et qui malheureusement
le cbb autorisé en france depuis que la
france ait été condamné le 19 novembre
par le tribunal européen nous
agriculteurs français on n'a pas droit
de le vendre donc avant de l'exporter
votre production pour être transformée
et qui revient en france bien après
barnes théoriquement si ce qu'il
faudrait que je fasse mais depuis trois
mois on a pris la décision d'être dans
l'illégalité de transformer de vendre en
france notre production de c'est légal
mais à la fois illégal quand on est
producteur français
est ce que c'est un vecteur important de
ressources pour vous est ce qu'on gagne
beaucoup voilà quand on cultive des
champs et peut-être demain du cannabis
ce pari créatif abat clairement là
actuellement je suis éleveur donc quand
comme tous mes collègues éleveurs
on est au rsa quasiment et de demain
avec la production de chanvre bien-être
de même de chambrer le très créatif je
vais peut créer de l'emploi sur mon
exploitation en plus en faisant une
production qui a des qualités
environnementales sociétales qui avait
ramené du pouvoir d'achat sur un
territoire comme des notes qu'on a
beaucoup besoin effectivement c'est n'y
a que des avantages
témoignage
quand je me vais partir me coupe la
parole
et pour vous c'est important de vous
positionner dans l'égalité comme ça vous
vous craignez pas une intervention de la
police
j'ai envie d un ennemi qui viennent
j'attends presque que ça enfin qui
viennent de m'arrêter je suis dans mon
droit je suis dans le droit européen
c'est pas la loi française c'est pas la
loi française mais la loi française elle
est illégale le cannabis médical dans
n'utilise en ce moment dans
l'expérimentation ça peut pas être
produits entre le thérapeutique pour
être produit en france il ya trois ans
les politiques vous avez écouté il y
aurait déjà des producteurs de cannabis
thérapeutique actuellement pendant les
deux ans et des producteurs étrangers
qui vont produire et donc on n'a aucune
visibilité en sachant qu'il faut au
moins deux ans pour monter une filière
française vous fait quoi alors dans
cette déesse par exemple dans cette
pièce on est ferme et claudine annoncé
un restaurant donc là on
on fait pousser des plants de chanvre
pour produire derrière des fleurs de la
résine de l'île sublinguale
d'autres préparations agroalimentaire on
peut en mettre partout du riche en gras
ça c'est tout ce qu'on a récupéré en
fait quand on a fait la manucure
l'associé de joigny chatou jérémy
gaillard est un ancien patron de cbd
shop passionnée par le chant vrai est
dérivé du
volume il va fabriquer devant nous une
plaquette de résine de cannabis
cb
ils expliquent le processus à médecine
qui vient apprendre ici le métier de
kebbi culteurs
donc le but du jeu en fait c'est que ça
tourne à une certaine vitesse pour que
ça monte à la moitié et après la résine
en fait va tomber et après
systématiquement chaque lot on envoie à
l'analyse pour être sûr d'être dans les
clous quoi on obligé de faire des gros
lots parce que chaque analyse ne coûte
quasiment 150 euros donc si là je fais
une plaquette que je fais mon analyse ça
vaut pas le coup
c'est un stagiaire il a suivi le
processus scolaire de lille c'est
l'institut supérieur de cannabiculture
donc c'est un diplôme
en ligne avec des cours en ligne vous
voulez faire quoique ce diplôme vous
voulez faire une entreprise de tana
lisible sur
entrepreneurs où je me suis dit allez
hop je pense que c'est un beau credo
quelque part il nous faisait quoi alors
moi j'ai
l'entrepôt depuis l'âge de 23 ans donc
j'étais content commerce devant le
bâtiment lâché dans la sécurité et hop
voilà j'ai plusieurs cordes à son arc
comme on doit
ça c'est la qualité que j'aimerais
pouvoir commercialiser en résine
directement datée sur vraiment une
résine de top qualité et je vais mettre
toute ma résine dans ce sachet je
referme dire mon petit sachet je
m'installe dedans
j'essaie de rester à 40
on est en train de faire du haschich
sauf que on a 1 - 2 th et que dans ce
qu'on peut acheter dans la rue mais
sinon on est vraiment sûr sur du
haschich du à chis cbd
utilisé au quart seulement 6 aucun
produit chimique
on a pas rajouté d'arômes artificiels de
cbd synthétique
serait le prix que tu peux retrouver
dans une bonne partie des produits du
marché donc là on est sur un produit que
tu peux vendre tes clients en étant fier
le prix de la plaquette
les plaquettes quand on les vend entière
a souvent dû à 350 euros au client final
et après on fait aussi des morceaux de 1
g 3 g 100 g 10 grammes qui sont revendus
au détail
les produits sont en vente à la ferme de
pigerolles et jérémy fournit déjà une
quarantaine de cbd shop dans la région
[Musique]
à paris jouanny est attendu pour une
audition auprès des députés de la
mission d'information sur le cannabis
à l'ordre du jour c'est une table ronde
qui les exploitants agricoles sur les
opportunités économiques ou non qu'ils
voient à leurs yeux du développement de
l'exploitation du chanvre et notamment
de son élargissement à l' usage de la
fleur c'est une question juridique
sanitaire politique qui vous appartient
de traiter dans la mission
bonjour donc monsieur chat tout
exploitant agricole dans la creuse
donc je suis producteur de chanvre
déjà trois ans et je milite activement
pour pouvoir utiliser la partie fleurs
du changement on était obligés de se
structurer en association l'association
française des producteurs cannabinoïdes
puisque on reçoit des appels de tous les
territoires alors cette année j'ai fait
une expérimentation à grande échelle
imprimés a déjà en termes d'emploi pour
la partie récolte manuelle de fleurs de
qualité moi j'estime pour ma ferme sur
deux mois c'est 15 saisonniers
juste pour 4000 mètres carrés de chant
si derrière on rajoute la transformation
et on fait les produits tout ça on je
pense qu'on est sur au moins quatre à
cinq emplois permanents à l'âne ou juste
pour ma ferme
[Musique]
je vois
plus tard
[Musique]
les travaux ne sont pas terminés dans
l'immeuble de romain il attend l'arrivée
des ambulanciers qui vont le conduire au
centre de la douleur de la professeure
attal
et c'est le grand jour pour lui c'est la
première fois qu'on va lui prescrire du
cannabis légal
[Musique]
bonjour aux mains ça va bien depuis les
dernières fois
les côtés oui vous continuer à filmer ou
les jeux continuent à fumer parce que
pour moi
vraiment ça qui me soulage si j'en crois
pas je ne peux pas dormir parce que j'ai
mal partout ce soir ils sont tous amis
donc c'est bien pour ça qu'on est
ensemble et parce que là on va commencer
donc effectivement le cannabis
thérapeutique
l'avantagé majeur c'est que ça vous
évitera de fumer ça mais j'espère que ça
permettra de diminuer d'arrêter ensuite
votre consommation de cannabis inhalé
parce qu'elle s'est quand même dangereux
pour vos poumons alors la zakat a glissé
du tout qui n'a pas du tout le même
risque je vais pas vous donner le ratio
c/b des dominants je vais vous donner un
ratio équilibré donc un ratio qui
contient moi qui ai été achetés moitié
cbd donc vous allez prendre le
traitement pour 28 jours et vous
commencez extrêmement doucement par
paliers et tous les 2 jours vous
augmenté de 0,1 millilitres lave le
grand avantage c'est que là on contrôle
nous même la dose on sait exactement ce
qu'il ya dedans et surtout il n'ya pas
le risque de l'inhalation et de tous les
traitements associés parce que dans les
cigarettes le risque évidemment il ya un
risque cancérigène lagaf a le risque
cancérigène les japonais continuent donc
n'y a pas de nicotine il n'y a pas de
goudron et à part ça c'est pas une
cigarette un double faveur par rapport
si vous ne faites arrêter par la police
d un seul faux pas conduire
non mais arrêtez pas que le sport dans
la rue
la police si jamais vous arrive et qu'il
ya quelque chose et qu'on fait un
contrôle de cannabis si vous montrez
leur donnant ce donc là vous allez
prendre cette ordonnance je le remets
vous allez descendre à la pharmacie et
la pharmacienne va vous expliquer vous
donnez le produit vous expliquer encore
une fois comment l'utiliser pour ne pas
se tromper et voilà ne vous inquiétez
pas je le respecterai je continue sans
mes commencer ce soir d'accord voilà je
vais commencer ce soir et en parallèle
je voulais dire mais c'est le reste ok
voilà très bien au revoir au revoir aux
professeurs
c'est une première à ce que ce que tes
premières est important pour vous ah oui
c'est très important mais on est très
content de pouvoir enfin prescrire à nos
patients ce type de produits mais en
même temps on est un tout petit peu
frustré et on sait qu'on ne va pas
pouvoir traiter tout le monde en fait
les parents de romain ont tenu à
assister à la première prise dans un
pays savent que le puits que refuse
je me sens mieux je dors mieux que
je crois que
ça il faut le mettre dans la bouche
un sous la halle
aux ouïes
ça c'est puissant
bon c'est parti
en fait c'est comme si tu prenais une
tête de peu dans la bouche
et non non c'est pas dégueulasse c'est
bon teint gouttes de dieu cofinancer un
goût de cannabis
bon maintenant la première c'est bien
poser une question posée aux paroles un
battant c'est important pour vous que
votre fils passe à cette médication
sur six au casier est ce que l'on sait
très bien qu'avec les médicaments et
actuel c'est pas forcément ce qui est
mieux la drôme abonnement
thiriez et tout ça c'est pas la
meilleure des choses dont tu vois là une
continuation
merci beaucoup me soutenir et puis moi
je suis plus dans l'inégalité
et ça c'est rassurant
bon ben je te fais un gros gros bisous
et puis je t'aime très fort
dans la creuse jouanny lui est toujours
dans l'illégalité cette nuit un petit
est né
sommes fin septembre bientôt le temps de
la récolte
c'est une fierté ses plans alors ces
plantes là toute la rangée l'un en fait
sa part d'une sélection qu'on a fait les
dernières sur une
variété du catalogue européen la con
politique on l'appeler qu'on paul thinel
en fait donc au lieu de monter à trois
mètres de haut elle est restée sous ce
format iscom comme ça celle qui est
derrière alors cette qui est derrière en
fait c'est exactement la même variété
mai
qui du coup et on va dire une génétique
normal qui a tendance à tige et vous
préparer pour voir vos propres plants à
vous en faites bah on sait que quand on
est agriculteur comme moi c'est toujours
intéressant d'avoir des semences
fermières qui sont adaptées au
territoire voilà au terroir d'avoir des
variétés qui montrent pas très haut les
dernières par exemple ça a été très
ventée on a eu beaucoup de casse sur le
chanvre qui sont aussi peu sensibles à
la sécheresse puisque là on n'a pas
arrosé du tout et on voit la couleur
c'est vert pétant les ont vraiment pas
du tout souffert de la sécheresse donc
voilà à faire des sélections comme ça
c'est intéressant toujours en restant
dans la loire reste en dessous des 0 2%
taché
jouanny a lancé un appel sur un site de
wwoofing en quelques heures il a reçu
plus d'une centaine de candidatures pour
faire la récolte pendant quinze jours en
échange du clos et du couvert
alors certes le cannabis passionnent les
jeunes mais la ferme de pigerolles
incarne aussi un renouveau pour une
agriculture à la fois moderne et
respectueuse de l'environnement
production d'électricité grâce au soleil
mais aussi de méthane à base de déchets
végétaux et bien sûr de bouse de vache
ici on rebelles et constructif
[Musique]
je suis resté
près d ici pour eux
pour fumer des pétards ah non pas du
tout pour avoir la connaissance sont la
plante
voilà c'est
ça nous intéresse beaucoup en fait aussi
le fait d'aider des gens qui sont
passionnés par la dans leurs prières je
sais pas s'ils ont un beau projet et ça
me fait vraiment et surtout pouvoir les
aider de pouvoir participer comme ça
juste que
ça devrait être légalisé quoi je suis
d'accord avec leur combat voilà beaucoup
des bénévoles avec plaisir
et on on s'instruit en même temps
avant d'être séché la plante doit être
débarrassée des grandes feuilles
d'inutile on appelle ça la manucure une
opération minutieuse qui demande
beaucoup de main d'oeuvre jérémy
l'associé de joigny trouvera peut-être
ici c'est prochain employés quand la
production de cannabis médical et de
bien-être sera légale en france
c'est quoi je vais variété jérémy afane
si c'est une plante de change du
catalogue européen c'est vrai ils
étaient là ont été créés principalement
pour travailler les
et les tiges et les graines qu'on a sur
les fleurs dans les tiges on a vraiment
tout la fibre sur le dessus qui va
servir à la confection de vêtements de
cordes et après dans les fleurs on va
récupérer
les graines en faire de l'huile
alimentaire nous on en fait une autre
utilisation nous là on récupère les
fleurs et c'est dans ces fleurs là qu'on
a vraiment tous les principes actifs de
la plante et qui servent à faire des
produits bien-être cosmétiques
exploité dans la halle à l'intérim moi
je suis atterré bah
moi je suis chaudronnier tuyauteur
autant dans l'industriel qui est dans le
particulier est belle comme cela à tous
les chômeurs qui sont en france qui se
lève tous les jours à 14h et puis qui
squattent les allocations les machins et
trucs comme ça et puis s'il pleut ça
toute leur vie c'est pas c'est pas une
vie pour moi et ça pourrait en créer de
l'emploi juste dans la mécanique aussi
fait que c'est d'abord
pour être avertir way henry bauchau
georges et à l'armée après j'étais dans
la grande distribution maintenant je
suis dans la mécanique ce qui fait que
maintenant sur une vie on peut faire
plusieurs métiers et pour la creuse pour
vous c'est important ça fait ça peut
dynamiser un territoire puisque le
département je dirais les vieillissants
le travail pour forcément y'a pas de
grosses entreprises en creuse pour faire
tourner un peu le pays vous êtes sûre du
made in france quand même
fabriqués localement
[Musique]
certes elle commence que tu fais là je
suis en train de téter en fait les tiges
je les ai peut-être pour conclure
récupérer qu'on voulait passer chez
derrière
donc toi aussi celle égaliser qu'est ce
que tu fais j'essaye j'essaie de partir
dans une unité de production légal bien
sûr
je fais des études en parallèle de ma la
profession effectivement je suis
paysagiste en cévennes en fait le
principe là par ces stages c'est de
connaître un petit peu le réseau qu'on
peut avoir en suisse en france ou en
espagne de se faire connaître par les
exploitants et de leur montrer ce qu'on
peut faire
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'industrie textile qui a
abandonné le chanvre pour promouvoir les
fibres synthétiques issus du pétrole
jusqu'aux années 50 toutes les fermes de
la région en cultivait pour ces jeunes
le cannabis c'est un retour au naturel
et au respect des terroirs
je suis maraîcher bio en fin
d'apprentissage d'ici deux ans je
m'installerai et puis je ferai ma ferme
donc là je suis là ici pour voir une
autre culture et puis bah voilà où en
plein plein de choses différentes je me
laisse je me laisse quelques années là
pour faire le tour des fermes en france
et voir ce qui s'y passe c'est une
culture de l'avenir je pense en fait
dans le futur si on ce n'est pas faire
du chanvre dulin qu'on produit pas des
fibres en france
on est on est sans cesse en fait à qui
demander du coton
en asie etc mais c'est pas des cultures
qui sont pérennes alors que le chanvre
ça pousse partout etc en antarctique que
ça coûte pas il n'y a pas besoin de hoya
pas besoin d'engrais donc s'il quand un
bus qui dépollue les sols consultants
qui est vraiment intéressante d'un point
de vue agronomique
en point de vue médicinales
va coûter c'est une tante était utilisé
depuis 4000 ans après ça je dis ça c'est
internet gpj n'était pas à moi je veux
dire la génération internet google c'est
mon deuxième papa quoi je sors de deux
suites de commerce mais ça m'a pas les
débouchés m'ont pas forcément plu et du
coup je me cherche et pourquoi pas
évolué en dents cette activité là et en
voir tout est débouchée niveau
d'isolation un peu l'industrie verte
quoi là tu vas avec
l'époque
moi je dis qu'il merveilleux d'entendre
les jeunes parler comme ça
ouais c'est bien
à
lui donc il faut changer
[Applaudissements]
la crise du coc bid a montré combien il
était important de garantir une
souveraineté industriels et sanitaires à
la france le chanvre ou cannabis semble
faire partie de ces produits essentiels
mais depuis sa première mission il y à
50 ans on avait tout simplement oublié
[Musique]
nous ne pouvons pas terminer ce film
sans retrouver romain une dernière fois
ce matin il est en dialyse à l'institut
montsouris à paris
les médicaments anti rejet pour sa
greffe de coeur ont endommagé ses reins
avec le cannabis je supporte mieux
psychologiquement
la contrainte de la dialyse parce que
c'est une vraie contrainte et ça peut
casser le moral et et moi ça fait un
effet bon ben c'est comme ça on prend
les choses un peu plus légèrement
aviation moi je veux aussi très bien
vous puissiez danseurs danseuses dans ce
protocole avec l'utilisation utilisé sur
ce produit je rentre dans ce cas mais il
ya tellement plein plein de pathologies
différentes où ça pourrait servir aussi
j'espère que bien sûr les alice pourra
être étendue
et ça fait maintenant trois mois que
romain prend du cannabis légalement à
l'hôpital de boulogne c'est l'heure d'un
bilan avec son médecin de la douleur la
professeure attal
si romain bonjour je vous aime ok ils se
voient tous les mois et ont peu à peu
augmenter la teneur en thc de son
traitement voilà
parfait
dites moi vous continuez le cannabis
thérapeutique est ce que vous avez aussi
réduire votre consommation par ailleurs
de cigarette parce que c'est le but
aussi il ya des fois je suis 2 on sait
bien ça depuis parfois je crains que
jean francis quoi oui mais avant vous
étiez beaucoup plus bas je sens déjà que
que je respire mieux que jeu -
donc airs expliqué accor fait
et par rapport à la douleur comment ça
se passe pas toujours facile mais par
rapport à la douleur
je trouve que le cannabis à
ath et doel nord
il est efficace il marche globalement
vous le supportez bien ça m'a pas de
problème pas d'intolérance pas d'effets
secondaires annuel à booster la bouche
sèche
là j'ai des questions sur la d'anxiété
ça va être un peu plus alors le
globalement est-ce que vous vous sentez
tendue ou énervés la plupart du temps
souvent de temps en temps ou jamais
je me d'accord est-ce que vous avez des
sensations de peur avec l'estomac noué
sur vous arrive ça comme des attaques de
panique non
en fait c'est très bien tout ça parce
que vous avez des scores faibles donc ça
c'est bien
nicolas authier il faut légaliser le
cannabis thérapeutique
oui il faudra probablement à terme
légaliser le cannabis à visée
thérapeutique les produits à base de
cannabis à visée thérapeutique en tout
cas il faudrait que les patients
puissent y avoir accès s'ils ne sont pas
soulagées convenablement par des
médicaments conventionnels
disponible et accessible
le maroc réfléchit désormais à la
légalisation du cannabis
au nom de ses vertus thérapeutiques et
de la manne économique qu'il représente
ça bouge encore ça bouge énormément
quand on est du côté parent malade ou
malades forcément s'amuse jamais assez
vite fait
[Musique]
cette recette vient cette passion de
cannabis
or bizarrement moi je fume pas du tout
j'ai jamais fumé de
cannabis
en fait c'est une plante qui est quand
même assez fascinante
un terre-plein de l'application
qui est très technique et en fait c'est
une plante qui s'adapte très bien aux
changements climatiques donc en fait
tous accumulés et en plus
c'est une forte qui peut faire du bien
aux jambes
en fait c'est que du bonheur de
travailler une pointe comme ça
[Musique]
on
où
[Musique]